there's a reason you ladies are not
supposed to actually ride motorcycles
you're just supposed to straddle them in
bikinis motorcycle and trampoline
accident at the same time statistically
she should be dead
trampolines will find a way to f you up
even when you're not jumping on them
literally the one spot in that giant
field she needed to avoid it doesn't
matter where you put that thing she was
gonna find a way to hit it a little
extra butter to a game of popcorn hey
double bounce that head over the fence
now it belongs to the beast Sandlot huh
Benny the jet Rodriguez nothing
Wendy peppercorn huh killing me smalls
moving on now quick get him to the
beauty parlor
then to the hospital good luck not
putting any weight on it
forget quarterbacks Ohio State can't
even keep their fat fans healthy you
have a death wish if you're trying
anything athletic and a Greg Oden Jersey
same goes for a DeRose Jersey or Johnny
football for Adrian Peterson or RG three
old bobblehead Peyton Manning chicken
parm you taste so good let's all watch
an there clip now I've always said the
only thing my green screen show is
missing is a trampoline now what will
that forty year old man do for fun it
should be harder for people to get a
trampoline than a gun
whenever you do don't let your dog chew
your foot they'll end up marrying it and
you're that weird guy with body parts in
his backyard
thank you for the towel I'll just use it
to call an ambulance quick someone
project a hospital onto that green
screen don't move our green screen yeah
new foot let's make it harder to watch
[Applause]
a show called the view shouldn't hurt
your eyes
you're a fortnight kid now the biggest
threat to suburban white teens in this
country is opioids close second
trampolines maybe someone just dared him
to rim himself I admire him for going
for it
well you bitch-ass parents are gonna
like to hear this but I think he would
have been fine if the net wasn't there
I've invented the safest way to enjoy
the deadly double bounce you can do it
anywhere except on a trampoline the only
requirement is that you respect the BB
c-- by saying boying
BB c BB C BB C boy so how's everything
taste of a b c BB c BB c bullying
BB C boy
BB C not since surprise trust Falls have
I created such a pointless sensation
post your own BB C vids and we'll send
you upwards of $100 upwards but most
likely 0 get a rebound not one person
crashed the boards
alright let's reset the shot clock and
take a look at how the kid dunked
himself in this week's breakdown
you never see rich people with
trampolines it's like an above-ground
pool it's just not an upscale piece of
lawn furniture hey at least they sprung
for the safety net what could go wrong
well here's one thing that could go
wrong the kids could start
double-bouncing it out of each other for
those of you who don't know what a
double bounce is it's the trampoline
equivalent of a speed ball for those of
you who don't know what a speedball is
its what killed John Belushi for those
of you who don't know who John Belushi
is he's Jim Belushi's brother for those
of you who don't know Jim is he's the
guy from according to Jim for those of
you who didn't watch according to Jim
congratulations oh wow is he up there
somebody just caught fire NBA Jam style
savor the moment Scotty Skiles because
it's about to turn sour that's a
technical foul get off the rim
yes suck it Vince Carter dangling by
your elbow doesn't seem like such a big
deal anymore
it hurts to hear this is where he and
his torn ACL could learn a lesson from
Sasha just distribute the ball set some
screens and draw defenders out of lane
so real players can put on a show and
why is he crying like Nancy Kerrigan
you're right you don't get to dunk
you